Now we'd also like to have a sound object that we can pass around or attach to
various entities in the rest of the game code. Say, for instance, that some
entity has a specific
[NOISE]
death sound that always plays. We'd want to be able to actually attach that to
that entity. As you can see here, we have a sound object that has two methods,
init, and play. Init, initializes the sound in any way we might need to. Play
takes a boullian loop that plays a sound and playSoundInstance, which is an
external function used by both init and play, is a fire and forget version that
takes a sound URL, loads it, and then immediately plays it. Now, we want you to
fill in these methods as described with everything we've already built. And
that should only be a few lines of code.